the probe used multiple sql injections
but i've yet to find any compromised
files
this is terrible when i first saw this
show
i shut down my tv that very second
hi i'm karen alizari a security
researcher author
and friendly hacker i've been in the
cyber security space for more than
25 years i'm the founder of israel's
largest hacker community
besides tel aviv and the leading cyber
ladies
today we're going to take a look at some
cool hacking clips from film and
television
and discuss how real is it
yikes i wouldn't do that that is
bad bad upset bad operational security
the computer might actually be
physically booby trapped well if i had a
computer like that i was bringing it in
for investigation
i might even x-ray it before i did
anything with it when we bring in a
device for a digital forensics
investigation
we usually open it up in a lab
environment not
in the middle of our agency office
[Music]
this is omega site i don't know the term
omega site i think that's just
added hollywood jargon to make it look
scary
most encrypted level he has it wouldn't
be a level it might be
a file or you know a segment of the hard
drive
uh there's no levels it doesn't look
like this
there's definitely no 3d you know moving
animations of what the file is doing
looks like obfuscated code to conceal
its true purpose okay that bit is real
yes you could obfuscate your code and
malware authors
often do this he's using a polymorphic
engine to mutate the code
whenever i try to gain access it changes
we have seen
polymorphic code specifically with
malware
so now we finally see a hex version of
the code
hex stands for hexa decimal
now hexadecimal means 16.
you typically can see only 16 characters
0 to 9
a to f you won't see g
you won't see r you won't see o
[Music]
you could do a lot of things with code
and it can be beautiful
but it's not going to look like a map
it's not going to have these
you know curly lines this is something
completely different i think this
is maybe 3 out of 10
and i'm just giving them some points for
you know putting in some actual real
world terms like
malware you know polymorphism and code
obfuscation
but that's pretty much where the realism
ends unfortunately mr bond
[Music]
we're in the middle of the final round
of the qualifier for a ctf so elliot and
darlene are visiting a hackerspace
that is currently hosting a ctf a ctf
is a capture the flag competition and
this is a type of hacker
games it might be about decrypting a
really
unique piece of code or something like
that so in this scene they're in the
qualifying rounds for defcon
and defcon is a real world hacking
conference it's the world's largest
hacking conference
there's even hackathons and ctfs that
take place
in italian farms i've been to ctfs at
convention centers university campuses
although the one they're at right now
is extra underground they let you save
and load your game restoring all the
minds you found and all the shells you
cleared
that's the weakness what elliot is doing
could be even considered quite rude
having somebody shoulder surf you like
that yes it does happen
however for elliot to you know within
one second
understand what's going on that screen
get all the context of that code and
then tell them how to win that challenge
i mean i understand the show of course
sets him up to be of above average
intelligence
but he would have to be like the super
computer the game trusts whatever data
you give it to recreate the board
poison the data you can make it run
whatever code you want it sounds like
the hackers need to reverse engineer or
to take apart
a minesweeper style game this sounds
quite realistic
it's actually based on the real world
ctf challenge from 2012.
so i think it's really cool the show
went to the trouble of getting a real
world hacking challenge
a ctf room can get loud it can get
sweaty it can get smelly it can be
electric
all i have to do is hack the registrar
and change the name server configs
what he's doing right now is very
realistic and
it would have taken him a lot longer
than it did
one does not hack a registrar
in two seconds elliot needs to get in
touch with the back door that they
planted
inside ecorp in the past season in order
to do that
he's utilizing the fact that backdoor
which is basically a
computer software has a hard-coded
c2 domain c2 in this context means
command and control and it's often times
where
hackers or you know malicious criminals
create a piece of code
that's going to run inside an
organizational network
but in order to be in a position to
communicate with the back door
elliot first needs to take over the
domain and the next thing he does
and we see him do it is issue the
command shred
shred is a unix command to not just
delete files but
also rewrite them so that the files
would be
much more difficult to recover even with
specialized forensic software
i'm gonna rate this scene at nine out of
ten
i'm only deducting the one point just
because of how
fast everything happened and how quickly
those hackers
let elliot jump into their ctf game
well we can tell she's a hacker she's
got all those stickers on her laptop
ninevol rihanna is using open source
intelligence which is a fancy term for
the internet
this is what's called a spear fishing
attack
she's not just going on a fishing
expedition she is
spear phishing she's targeting this
particular individual
with an email with a topic something
that he's really you know passionate
about
there are definitely attacks out there
that would give an attacker control over
your webcam
and they could even turn on your webcam
and you wouldn't know that it's on
but it typically takes a little bit more
time and a tiny little bit more
interaction on the side of the victim
they would maybe run an application
install something it will take a little
bit extra
[Music]
these types of physical boxes that would
allow you to
unlock any passwords don't really exist
for computer passwords many of you have
have a phone that if you put in
the four digit pin or seven digit pin
and you get it wrong
the phone will get wiped after five or
ten
wrong attempts so those physical boxes
in the real world used mostly by law
enforcement
would bypass that using all kinds of
different tricks but they would require
physical access to be connected with a
cable to their target
device to the phone it makes sense that
they require an additional
password just to get access to that
particular software
that's cool that makes sense however
this looks like a 12
character password and it's got not just
numbers but also uppercase lowercase and
special characters
for a password of that length it would
it would have about 94 to the power of
12
different possible combinations that's a
number so big that i can't even spell it
out you'd have to use the whole screen
just right down
right here there is no way an electronic
box could crack that and if nine ball
has a box like that
it's more valuable than whatever it is
they're gonna steal from the
metropolitan museum
i would probably say the first part
about the spear fishing
is extremely realistic but then it kind
of loses
the realness uh so i'm gonna average
it at seven out of ten
i think it was the turning point where
hollywood started showing
realistic hacking so what we're seeing
here is that trinity is using
nmap which is a legit network scanning
and mapping tool
that hackers use all the time
we also see her using something called
ssh nuke
so ssh nuke refers to secure shell and
ssh nuke
is according to the movie basically an
attack against the
ssh service where she's taking advantage
of a specific vulnerability
and it's even telling us it's attempting
to exploit ssh
version 1 crc 32 so this was
a real world vulnerability in ssh
that was only discovered maybe about a
month before
this film went to set so as somebody
was working on the screen right as they
were in pre-production
this vulnerability in that piece of code
was discovered
and they already featured it in the
movie which i think is extremely
timely extremely accurate
the only tiny element here that isn't
isn't that realistic
is that she is resetting the password if
she successfully exploits that
vulnerability
the exploit would give her root
privileges she wouldn't necessarily have
to reset the password
there's no way she could hack like that
and not make a ton of typos
all the hackers know you need fingerless
gloves to type fast
i'm going to rate this scene at 9.5 out
of 10.
and i'm taking away half a point just
because of the gloves girl
so lisbeth here is doing the groundwork
she is casing her target
what she's doing is basically hanging
out
and catching hearing the code
as it's being touched in the keypad
and it sounded like one two one two
which looks like what she's pressing so
in the real world it's not that
difficult to understand what the
different digits
sound like if you train your ear to it
she's not going to mess around with it
she's not going to plug her computer and
be seen doing all kinds of nefarious
things
she's going to take photos get out of
there and then analyze those photos to
see exactly
what the hardware setup is what the
router is what the type of communication
setup is in that apartment building
and then she procures a specific device
from one of her fellow hackers i think
that's very realistic
looks like a you know a hacker space
looks like a lot of places i've visited
definitely
the device itself is hard to say exactly
what it is we see that it's a nokia
this might be in reference to something
called the nokia n900
which used to be known in hacker circles
as the phone phone
uh and it was a phone that was used
primarily for
wireless network hacking however it
didn't look exactly like
this so this might be a specialized
device it might be a tablet that's got
both
a cellular connection and a network
interface
it might be something similar to this
the device she's using in the movie is a
little bit dramatized it's a device
that you can plug into the ethernet
that's where you put in the network
connection
and it also has room for a sim card so
you put in a sim card it's got a
cellular uplink
and you plug it into the wall it's
actually designed to look like an air
freshener
and if i was doing a security assessment
i would sneak
in just like lisbeth does i would plug
this into the electricity
into the network and then i would use
the cellular connection
to basically from my remote hacker
hideout
to plug in call up this bad boy and
run some network assessments see what i
can sniff see what i can capture
on that network so based on what we just
saw i'm going to give it
10 out of 10. it's a very realistic
scene
[Music]
billy olsen sitting here and had the
idea of putting some of the pictures
next to pictures of farm animals and
have people vote on who's hotter
so apparently mark zuckerberg indeed
live
vlogged everything that's going on in
the scene
when he created his face mesh so
everything that he's writing i'm gonna
assume the screenwriters grabbed from
his actual blogs
in a number to represent each person's
hotness like they do on hotonhop.com
a website called am i hot or not was
around it was very popular unfortunately
harvard doesn't keep a public
centralized facebook so i'm going to
have to get all the images from the
individual houses that people are in so
he has to tweak his
script or has to tweak his process to
match the specific houses which is very
realistic even today
academic institutions internal web pages
are
a spaghetti of different types of code
bases
and servers they require a username
password for one of the houses he
is required to provide a username and
password
and the movie shows us for a split
second that he's got the
m zuckerberg log in but then we see he
logs in with another username
called bolson this is a hack this is a
moment where he uses somebody else's
access and that would be you know
probably against the computer fraud and
abuse act
certainly against the harvard rules of
engagement
dumpster is intense that may be
difficult i'll come back later
this is very realistic if there's one
that poses an additional layer
or additional challenge we won't spend
too much time on it we will circle back
and get back to it
and this is also what the criminals do
they go for the low-hanging fruits they
go for the easier targets first
and only later or if they're trying to
achieve a very specific goal
they would go for the target that's even
marginally harder
you want to have that additional layer
of effort for the bad guys to get in
they break out emacs and modify that
pearl script
and the movie represents it as if it all
took place over one drunken evening
where in the real world it took him at
least a couple of nights
he was obviously very capable with what
he was doing but these are no
zero-day exploits these are not novel
innovative attacks that we've never seen
before basically he is automating the
process of grabbing
images from web servers so
something quite simple i would give it
nine out of ten
i think the only unrealistic elements
here is the
basically the fast forward that they did
to make everything happen within one
dramatic evening
hack them all
this hack is actually based on a real
world hack that was demonstrated
about a year before this movie came out
so back in 2015
charlie miller and chris valachik
demonstrated that they can remotely hack
a 2014 jeep cherokee using the
infotainment system
i don't think it would have been
realistic in 2016
and might not even be realistic today
for a hacker to be able to get
into a lot of different makes and models
of cars
even the best automotive security
researchers
would struggle with remotely turning
on the ignition for a car that doesn't
already have a feature like that built
in however in the future we're gonna see
cars that are much more connected than
ever before
this could be a very scary realistic
scenario
they are using i guess unlimited
computing power
to coordinate the movements of all of
these vehicles
if you think about it even if you have
remote control of a vehicle's
steering you would still need to have a
satellite view of where all the cars
were going
and to somehow coordinate all of them to
make them all go
in you know the same direction or where
you want them to hit
so let's go for seven out of ten i'm
taking away points for
how easy everything is cypher already
has everything set up
all she has to do is click on a tablet
[Music]
i have definitely done that in the past
so
looking for a note looking for a piece
of paper that's going to have
the password for the system that you
want to access
people write down their passwords but
even you know further than that people
recycle their passwords i just have to
go to some of the many
databases of leaked passwords and i can
easily find
that you had five or six different
accounts where you use the same password
so i'm gonna bet that you're gonna use
that same password or a very close
variation of it
for a lot of your other online services
and
hackers do this all the time it's called
credential stuffing
and we're just going to stuff them and
try and see if any account
any system lets us log in it's super
easy
for hackers to look over your social
media posts or maybe even when you're on
a zoom call
and you've got that posted with the
password just behind you there
you want to enable things like
two-factor or multi-factor
authentication and sometimes that
additional layer of security could also
be
biometrics this scene gets
10 out of 10 for accuracy i've done it
myself
arium how are we doing on that data core
audit the probe used multiple sql
injections
but i've yet to find any compromised
files this is terrible
this is horrendous so i gotta tell you
when i first saw this show
i shut down my tv that very second
to think that a space probe
in the future in space somewhere would
use something like an
sql injection to attack a
federation spaceship so sql
injections are something that hackers
use
nowadays you're banking on the fact that
the sql server
is gonna run whatever you input
and this is ironic because
sql was first created in the
1960s or 1970s so maybe the writers of
the show
are basically telling us that we're
stuck with sql
for the foreseeable future i give it
one out of them so they log on to our
boxes and our boxes log on to the real
wifi
between everyone's device the scenario
that's described in the scene is very
realistic and they're using a real-world
device a wi-fi
pineapple made by hack5 what i've got
over here is the wi-fi pineapple nano
which is a much smaller version of the
routers that they used in the show and
it's designed to be very stick
so you could walk around with something
like this in your backpack and
nobody would be the wiser so any phones
or computers
walking around the vicinity of a device
like this would be logging on to this
instead of the legitimate access point
that they think they are logged onto
and they wouldn't be able to tell the
difference so we show them a fake
landing page and force everyone to
download a doctored version of the
hooligan
app the second part of the hack is also
realistic
they're using their control of the wi-fi
to point people to a website
they control made up to look like the
holy conference website i would rate
this
at 10 out of 10.
i highly doubt that the cia would have
servers that would be accessible over
the internet
while she's on that server all the files
are organized really neatly in cool
folders
with all the covert projects names now
this may seem unrealistic
but actually a year after this film came
out we actually saw something called
vault 7 which was featured by wikileaks
which was an
actual leak from the cia and they did
have a lot of their covert operations
including their hacking tools organized
in files and folders like that
it doesn't look like any security
monitoring tool that i know
however what's probably happening here
is that
nikki is using a back door that somebody
has
already set up from inside the cia
so basically nikki's computer is sending
packets to specific ports on
the cia's computer and after a specific
sequence
so a packet sent let's say to port 7000
port 8000 port 9000 the cia's computer
accepts that
as a secret handshake and opens up a
connection
from inside the cia to nikki's computer
this is a realistic capability
again they're using a basic capability
trace route is something that even your
windows computer could do
any unix computer could do but the cia
has that
added extra stuff they put in there
that's going to correlate it
not just to a physical location
somewhere in the world
but also to the accurate gps coordinates
[Music]
secops hacking camp so it's remarkable
the cia
instantly knows that location they know
it's a hackerspace
they know all the hackers in the world
and they know where they live kill the
power to the building you know this is
not a capability
that an intelligence agency is going to
flaunt
if they have such a capability to
remotely kill the power
to a specific building when hackers
hacked the electricity system
in kiev in the ukraine in 2015 and then
again in 2017
they took down the power for chunks of
the city
and it took them months to set up that
hack i don't know if this is something
that could be realistically
done in such a targeted manner to one
house in particular
we see ip addresses that are simply
impossible for example an ip address
that begins with 300
so ip addresses are made up of four
octets four segments each octet
has three digits the digits of course
could be zero so
it could be anything from zero to
255. any time in the movies you see an
ip address that starts with
you know that's like 257
it's bogus it doesn't exist in the real
world
if i'm hacking i will probably have some
tools that are going to alert me
if my computer is being scanned or
tracked but it would not look like this
i'm going to give it a 6
out of 10 rating they did include some
very realistic things
but bogus ip addresses that's not gonna
fly
[Music]
okay so hackers is my ultimate
all-time favorite hacker movie it's the
reason
i chose to become a hacker in the first
place this is what it looks like when
somebody is analyzing a piece of code
an entire night goes by a montage passes
us by
he needs all that time and he's got
friends and they're you know eating cold
pizza
drinking warm energy drinks that's the
hacker menu i grew up on
this is every financial transaction
ellingson conducts yeah
now we actually see hexadecimal on the
left and to the right
the ascii characters or the financial
transactions
that the hex code would actually
represent
in the ellingson corporation's computer
systems
so this is fairly realistic the
antagonist is using
the davinci virus they basically created
a very destructive virus that's
threatening to capsize the ellingson
mineral corporation's oil tankers
if it's not paid a million dollars mind
you this is the first case of ransomware
that hollywood has ever depicted before
ransomware became a thing
in the real world nowadays we have a lot
of attacks like this
where criminals take over your computer
system and request a payment in order to
decrypt
the files and give you back access to
your systems so
while it wasn't accurate back when the
film took place in the 90s
i think it really predicted the future i
would love to give this
10 out of 10. um i'm gonna take away
two points a couple points just because
we don't
actually see any of the software code
it's not recycling your passwords it's
not a good kind of recycling don't do it
in fact i got a t-shirt somewhere that
says hackers don't break in
we log in and that's fairly accurate